I don't think it's that that like
they're they're like oh we don't like
Ashley and Jared I think it's just they
were like why are we watching the
married couple uh everybody's so mad at
us yeah Bachelor Nation didn't hold back
about Jared and Ashley's return to the
beach give me a kiss and then let's go
ride jet skis
I think the show took a chance on us on
like showcasing hey this is what like
love looks like after the show
unfortunately people didn't really like
watching it sometimes and that makes it
sad the reality stars are a Bachelor in
Paradise success story
people just don't know how much this
beach means to Ashley and I yes it's the
first place we met it was a rocky road
in the beginning but it really formed a
strong friendship that turned into a
strong relationship our first day seven
years ago on this very Beach and now
here we are
with wedding rings on our hands yep
drinking champagne
with a baby
Paradise we really got to just like dive
into this is this is the reasons why
we're together and we talk about Dawson
and that was really important for us
because you know
when we were able to reflect on the fact
that we're parents now and like
you know I think of my dad and now I'm
his dad yeah you know
it's a lot but a peek into life after
the beach got mixed reviews from fans
and season 8 singles so the date card
today goes to Jared and Ashley the only
people who do not really need a date
listen I love the show so much but
Paradise this year is quite the
commitment there's 16 episodes yeah I
mean there's 16 episodes that is usually
that's six more than usual that is 12
more hours so you know they were like
what can we do that's interesting and
unique let's bring a married couple down
see how the love transpires through the
years
and I guess people don't really want to
see it and everybody is like nice to us
there but then like behind our backs oh
my God what are they doing here like
they gotta get out let's just like get
out you're not invited and honestly I
thought like we'd go down there and we
would be indifferent like it would be
like quick little scenes but we um we
are kind of sad that we heard like a lot
of people are fast forwarding through
our date scene which actually was very
meaningful to us so you have changed
because you've really embraced yourself
so much more because you are just so
much more yourself like you're so much
less Garden I think you just make me a
happier person you make me a better man
it's not just in our marriage either
because you really are my best friend
just I would never want life without you
it's interesting because people who say
they watch the show because they love
love seeing real love and you're seeing
you know love after the show and what
that entails and what that means and now
in Parenthood listen I would never
change a thing and honestly a lot of
people have been really nice as late uh
but I think it just makes us sad because
I think we it makes us feel like
failures you know I think all of us here
on the beach would have liked to be on
that date card but we'll gladly take a
backseat to Jed and Ashley they deserve
it just tell they're just deeply in love
and you know that's why we're all here
that you know I want what they have
that's what we're all looking for right
there might be a reunion show in the
future
um so they might have to just
get through seeing us one more time just
get through and use that stripe
[Music]